we begin with first hopes of a
breakthrough over the war in ukraine
president vladimir zelinski's office
says it will hold talks with russian
officials at the border with belarus
russia says its delegation has flown in
for the talks it's not clear when
negotiations might begin
in other developments president vladimir
putin has put russia's nuclear forces on
alert in an escalation of tensions with
the west the u.s has accused him of
manufacturing threats
fighting continues on the ground in
ukraine russian forces have attacked
fuel depots and there are reports of
explosions outside the capital kiev the
mayor says there are no russian troops
in the city battles are still going on
around other population centers
for more let's bring in dw correspondent
nick connolly who is in vinitskaya in
western ukraine nick why has president
zielenski agreed to talk with russia now
i think it's really important also for
the ukraine's diplomatic efforts even if
this doesn't reach any results just to
show that ukraine is open to
negotiation is open to a deal i think
it's all a question of on what terms are
those deals struck and also even on what
terms are those talks held so the
russian side today arrived in the
belarusian provincial of gomol which is
just near the ukrainian border it's in
the region from which attacks are still
being launched on kiev every day and
they were expecting ukrainians across
the border into a country belarus which
is basically supporting this russian
military effort with supplies with lo
with
access to its bases and the ukrainians
kind of it was expected by the russians
would just arrive to sign some kind of
capitulation and give in to russia's
demands that was also something that the
ukrainians weren't going to agree to so
i think this was an attempt by the
russians to kind of show the world look
the ukrainians just aren't interested in
conscious constructive dialogue that's
why we have to fight this war because
they're not turning up for these talks
we're offering them so william zalenski
tried to show the rest of the world that
ukraine deserves support that it is
trying to find a solution but it's not
going to be dictated to from moscow how
these talks happen and where they happen
i think it's just pretty extraordinary
to imagine you know going for talks in a
country that is helping another country
to attack you
regardless of how these talks end up
evolving is there any indication about
when these supposed peace talks could
take place
i think it's a bit early to think about
dates for now there's lots of
conflicting messaging going on about
when that's going to happen um but the
readiness is there but fighting
continues so i think it's kind of hard
to see how they're going to really
reach any results while people are still
dying in kiev that's a really difficult
question especially given what you just
said nick but what can we expect from
these talks too early to say
i mean the russians are going all out
their demands from ukraine there as it
was put by top russian officials and
putin was denotification and
demilitarization of ukraine get rid of
ukraine's military so it can't defend
itself in future and they basically
branded ukraine's entire leadership as
neo-nazis which is fairly extraordinary
given that they got to power through
democratic elections ukraine's president
is of jewish extraction um the russians
haven't provided any proof of these
claims basically they were trying to
delegitimize ukraine's leadership and
basically say roll over take our terms
anything else it'll be war so given that
extraordinarily aggressive negotiating
position it's very hard to see where
deal can be struck but i think for now
it's about showing outside world that
ukraine is willing to talk even though
these conflicts and the shooting goes on
uh whether it actually achieves anything
i think is questionable that's a nick
connolly uh there in ukraine many many
thanks nick
a turning point in the history of our
continent that's how chancellor olaf
schultz described russia's war against
ukraine speaking to a special session of
parliament the german leader announced a
raft of policy changes that would have
been unthinkable just days ago germany
will drastically strengthen its military
and move quickly to eliminate its
reliance on russian energy exports he
put the blame squarely on russian
president vladimir putin who he said had
brought decades of peaceful coexistence
to an end the german chancellor earlier
today
putin
putin wants to create a russian empire
he wants to reconfigure europe according
to his own ideas and he does not
hesitate to use military violence
we see this today in ukraine
so we must ask ourselves what
capabilities putin's russia has
and what capabilities do we need to meet
this threat today and in the future
we must invest more in the security of
our country to defend our freedom and
democracy
from now on year for year more than two
percent of our gdp will be invested in
defense
i'm joined now by our chief political
editor mikhail kofner
i think it's probably safe to say that
this was a historic moment for german
foreign and defense policy
absolutely this is a paradigm shift in
german defense policy uh frankly we've
seen more change in that in the past 24
hours than in the previous 24 years that
is now safe to say it started when
saturday evening we got news that olaf
schultz is now planning for germany to
directly deliver weapons to ukraine
although we're not sure yet in which
shape or form that handover will
actually take place and then today we
heard from a social democrat chancellor
whose chief whip in parliament is really
leaning in the direction of having to
having tried to understand russia in the
past more of a pacifist kind of angle
well he out of all people now announced
these 100 billion on top of the ordinary
defense budget that's twice more than
twice the current defense budget here in
germany and he's also agreed to above
two percent of gdp going into defense
the latest as of 2024 this is something
donald trump tried to get the germans to
move towards throughout his tenure and
failed and this has all just happened
over the past 24 hours
you make mention of the agreement to
send weapons to ukraine another major
sea change is russia's war rewriting
european security policy
yes it is olaf said we've woken up in a
new era and that's how it truly feels
also speaking to mps here in german
parliament today um amongst the biggest
skeptics that
having a deterrent having a strong
military really would be a way forward
in such modern times particularly in
relation with russia which
geographically is so important to
germany and europe
it is now sunk in
one from one day to the other
that the limits of dialogue have been
reached in fact we heard direct appeals
towards the russian people that all
politicians speaking here today were
great pains to differentiate between
russia and vladimir putin calling it
putin's war and not russia's war on
ukraine
leading to uh basically
predicting that also in russia democracy
and freedom would prevail in the end
well this is very much sounding like
those who are against vladimir putin to
now stand up to him within his own
country
you well know michelle there have been
large protests here and abroad demanding
more help for for ukraine uh what role
does public opinion play here
well it does play a huge role but
frankly
what we heard here today didn't wait for
any opinion polls
germans are very conservative very
restrained when it comes to having any
kind of engagement uh internationally of
their own military forces um in fact the
whole of german society is if anything
anti-military
[Music]
in terms of applying military pressure
anywhere in the world that's also why
german parliament has to agree on any
forces being deployed abroad because of
germany's dark past so yes all our
shorts could be sure that a broad
majority would
back him on his actions but this is
really leading the way this goes beyond
what the now opposition angela mackle's
conservative party ever would have dared
to ask from their former coalition
partner the social democrats
that's chief political editor mikhail
kofner many thanks
i'm now joined by ben hodges a former
u.s army officer who served as
commanding general united states army
europe and co-authored a book future war
and the defense of europe in 2021
general it's good to have you with us
germany has pledged to spend more than
two percent of its budget on defense
something the u.s has been pushing for
years your reaction
well obviously i'm i'm proud to see
germany our most important ally
uh accept this responsibility and this
always had to be a decision by germany
not something imposed on germany it had
to be a decision by germans and so now
the bundestag and the and the german
government uh accepting this
responsibility and
it's welcome
i'm not sure whether you know this but
just very recently putin um just uh
just put out russia's nuclear deterrence
forces
on higher alert um what do you make of
this
well uh nobody should be surprised that
that he would do this uh of course it
cost him
nothing nothing to threaten the use of
nuclear weapons they've been doing this
for years and all of their exercises
but it will cost him everything if they
should make the terrible calculation to
employ
a nuclear weapon no matter how large
or small it will cause him and russia
everything
i think it's also important
to keep in mind that belarus vice versa
is having a referendum to date
and that referendum will include
welcoming nuclear weapons into belarus
it'll change the constitution to allow
nuclear weapons in belarus it'll change
the constitution to remove the word
neutrality from the constitution
and it will also give president
lukashinko immunity for life this is
happening today in belarus and so this
increases the problem with uh russian
nuclear weapons
i want to get back for a moment to
what's happening on the ground at the
moment did you ever think
that the ukrainian forces would hold
which is what they appear to be doing
for the time being against one of the
most powerful armies in the world
well um of course i've watched ukraine
now over the last eight years since they
were first invaded in 2014 and the
united states and canada and uk and
poland and lithuania have been working
hard with our ukrainian partners to help
improve their capability
but the real credit goes to ukrainian
soldiers uh i have been so impressed
with what's happened over the last four
or five days
um the the
we know from history that the will to
fight the heart
is uh even more important than what type
of weapons you have
i would also say that the russians have
revealed that they are not as good
as
we had maybe uh assumed just because
they're
large they have not
they do not have any real experience at
large-scale joint operations at the
operational level
like this and so many of their mistakes
they're making
uh their vulnerability
the logistics vulnerability is becoming
very apparent right
not to sound like an apologist or
proponent of any forces here but based
on what you've seen
is it possible russia hasn't yet fully
unleashed the full
might of its forces on ukraine for
whatever reason
well that's a fair question uh there
there has been speculation
that uh they were employing
their um
let's say uh less ready forces um using
um
chechens using conscripts
in the opening phases in some parts so i
can't confirm that i don't know how much
of that is true
certainly they have used a lot of their
airborne forces and their special forces
uh in the early days in the early hours
and most of them were defeated so
there's no doubt they have more
capability um that they could bring into
the fight
but i'm not sure
uh that they are prepared for this
logistically i mean it is hard this is
very difficult the amount of ammunition
uh that is expended in modern war is
much more than we ever anticipate same
thing for fuel
okay that is uh mr ben hodges former
commander of u.s army europe many many
thanks sir
thanks for the privilege
as we just heard russian president
vladimir putin has put his deterrence
forces including nuclear armed forces on
higher alert in a video speech
distributed by the kremlin putin said
that nato paris had made aggressive
statements toward russia he also cited
economic sanctions that will cut off
major russian banks from international
transactions
and from vilnius i am now joined by
constantine agar dw russians affairs
expert uh content constantine welcome
again uh what do you make of this high
alert order
well as a former officer i
had a very big problem discerning what
actually president putin meant he never
served in the army but his
commander-in-chief
the expression he used to indicate some
kind of heightened state of uh russian
armed forces does not exist in russian
military manuals uh a form which is
called he used an expression uh which is
roughly translated like heightened
military duty state
uh there are only four states of alert
in in russian military manuals uh
regular heightened
uh
threat of war and full
or complete
i mean maybe he tried to say that this
is heightened
frankly speaking very interesting a very
interesting detail uh nuclear forces are
pretty much always on python
uh so
what he probably wanted to say is that
uh they are going to now fuel the
missiles in the silos they are probably
going to uh give directions to
the
bombers uh with nuclear bombs uh that
are on permanent duty
in the air 24 7 actually
but we don't know whether it's true
and uh we don't know whether it's uh uh
for real or whether it's an attempt to
uh pressure the west and pressure
actually the ukrainian delegation at the
peace talks uh into concessions whether
it's a threat to basically gain more
leverage
is this a sign that putin is getting
desperate
the war has not gone according to plan
so far
well i suspect that
he
should be thinking about doing something
and let's hope it's not doing doing
something doesn't mean nuclear war but
it's not going to plan
i think already we already talked about
it i think it's it's uh
it's frankly speaking a pr disaster
already and probably it is a military
disaster for one of the world's
superpowers not to be able to overwhelm
um a force which was described by the
russian commander russian commentators
russian politicians is inferior to to
to the russian forces everyone was
saying just like four days ago uh
russian officials were saying well
ukrainians will kind of run away um it
didn't happen
so i think that he wants to gain more
leverage but on the other hand it's
interesting uh the russian delegation is
going uh to meet a ukrainian delegation
on the border of russia oh sorry ukraine
and belarus
uh and i wonder whether it's a uh kind
of
a tactic of diversion which could well
be the case or an attempt to start at
least some kind of dialogue my suspicion
alas unfortunately it's the former and
uh because ukrainians will never agree
to any demands for neutrality now
uh it may be designed to give uh the
kremlin an excuse to start an even more
vicious campaign uh of for example
shelling the cities with uh
surface-to-surface missiles that's what
i'm afraid of
that's uh constantine aggregate many
thanks
we have some breaking news to report an
advisor to ukraine's interior ministry
says those peace talks between russia
and ukraine have in fact started
meanwhile russian forces are meeting
stiff resistance as they attempt to push
further into ukraine the mayor of kiev
says the capital is holding its
defensive lines and there are no russian
troops in the city and after reports of
heavy fighting in eastern khaqib the
regional governor says ukrainian forces
have retaken full control of the city
russia's latest attacks have targeted
civilian infrastructure and the military
chaos at an oil depo in vasikev just
outside of kiev
services battled to the early morning
after russian rocket fire destroyed the
facility
it's just one of the many targets of
russian fire overnight
[Music]
that night was hard what did they do
this is revenge the people rose to
defend their state and they the russian
army showed their real face this is
terror
they're going to bomb our ukrainian
cities even more they're going to kill
our children even more insidiously this
is evil
russia has confirmed it destroyed what
it called 975 military targets in the
campaign so far
but many of its rockets have landed in
civilian areas killing and maiming
bystanders
here in kiev civilians continue to seek
shelter in the city's subway stations
there's little hope it seems for a quick
end to the fighting
karolina lindholm billing joins us now
from keeve she's with the office of the
united nations high commissioner for
refugees thank you for being with us and
if you'll forgive me and let me ask you
a personal question which is just simply
how are you
thank you i think i'm i'm shaken like so
many others from in many ways i mean i
spent a couple of hours in the in the
basement in the bunker last night and
i'm of course extremely concerned about
my colleagues working in the east i have
colleagues in mario paul severo donetsk
dinipro as well as in lugansk
and in central kievan and they're
spending a big part of the days um in
bomb shelters to protect themselves from
harm
and so far you appear to be safe and
that's good news does the latest news
that ukraine agrees to hold talks with
russia give you hope
i anything that gives hope that can end
you know this this uh
yeah military offensive that's creating
a huge humanitarian emergency on top of
one that already existed
since 2014 and 2015.
tens of thousands of ukrainians are on
the roads as you very well know what are
you seeing from where you are in the
capitol
so what we're seeing we're in
regular daily contact with internally
displaced persons local communities
local authorities um in the country who
are reporting about the arrival of
ukrainians who have fled from their
homes and what they're saying really is
they need
you know roof over their heads shelter
food
blankets like really
key ite you know basic necessities at
this moment as they are fleeing and
trying to figure out you know where
where they are going and to that end
what is the unhcr doing on the ground in
kiev to help them
so in kiev it's very challenging at the
moment because of the the security
situation and overall um providing
humanitarian assistance in this context
where the security situation is so
difficult and critical and unpredictable
is a huge challenge but we are working
on
establishing you know a way to do this
through idp community groups local
authorities and partners who we've been
working with over the years because the
needs are are immediate and they are
really growing by the way
we have to leave it there but we'd
certainly like to see you again that's
karolina lindholm billing with the
office of the united nations high
commissioner for refugees many thanks
in berlin a demonstration calling for
peace in ukraine is underway police say
more than a hundred thousand people are
taking part the demonstration is
organized by a variety of groups
including workers unions and religious
and environmental groups protesters are
calling on russia to withdraw
immediately from ukraine and to respect
democracy and human rights in the past
days there have been numerous
demonstrations across the world to
support ukraine and demand an immediate
end to violence
our political correspondent thomas
sparrow is covering the story for us
here in berlin where the demonstration
is taking place thomas uh generally how
many people would you say are there and
what's the atmosphere at this point
so actually most people are now leaving
so the protest is in the process of
ending but a few hours ago it was really
extremely full right here in the center
of berlin you may see the brandenburg
gate behind me and the other end of the
demonstration was another of berlin's
emblems the victory column between the
two it was really full the atmosphere
was a very friendly one people were
really all united in asking for peace
that's something that we were really
able to see when we spoke to people from
different nationalities and also
different generations so from a
grandmother of six who was concerned
about the war to families with young
children who were asking for politicians
to do more to protect children it has
also been a very international protest
altogether from what we've been able to
to gather here talking to people from
different nationalities they have
clearly stressed that they believe that
putin's attack on ukraine is not only an
attack on ukraine but it is an attack on
the international community as well
that's one of the reasons why they're
now here in berlin altogether
authorities have stressed that there are
around 100 000 people who have gathered
here in the center of berlin the images
that we've seen
certainly show that amount of people but
obviously from the ground from what we
can see here now it is also slowly
emptying it was indeed a very important
protest in berlin today for those who
want this war to end who want germany to
do more as well and who specifically
want to support ukraine
thomas less than half a minute but uh we
we sure saw massive people are they
supporting arms deliveries to the
ukrainian forces and the exclusion of
russian banks from the swift system
which could very well well hurt russian
people
absolutely they're supporting that
they've wanted for a long time in fact
some of the protests that i covered in
the last few days they specifically
wanted that so many people are actually
happy at least the ones that we spoke to
about the fact that germany has now
changed course so certainly another
element here is not only about showing
that they want peace showing that
they're against vladimir putin it's also
they want the german government to do
more they have wanted the german
government to do more for a long time
and this is something that they clearly
showed here in berlin today
that is thomas sparrow in berlin many
thanks thomas
you